okay there is the man my buddy from NFL
Network NFL Media Group my Pro Football
Hall of Fame friend Kurt Warner here on
this first ever zoom edition of the Rich
Eisen show I just switched views you
know I'm already getting into it
wherever where I can actually push
buttons like a director how are you Kurt
I'm doing all right
you know family's good we're all healthy
and just hunkering down and trying to
get through this like everybody else so
but it's good to have everybody together
and you know some quality time probably
more than I've had in a long time so
I've been at standpoint I'm just trying
to enjoy it
so are you did you just get more working
am i seeing like fresh off of work right
here yeah well I got one earlier this
morning and then Cade my my middle son
is back from Nebraska so we just had a
little basketball basketball workout
before before I jumped on so yeah just
trying to stay active as you know just
staying busy well I just started the
show by talking about how I think that
Brady is gonna make this team an 11 12
win team and Tampa and I'm wondering if
you think that's an immediate
overreaction what do you think Kurt um
no I don't think it's an immediate
overreaction I mean I think this was a
team that had a chance to win 10 games
or so last year outside of some
turnovers by Jameis as I heard you were
talking about but at the same time I
think you're talking about a team that's
in a tough division first and foremost
and they've got a tough schedule so
although I know Tom Brady and we're
enamored by that whole thing and how
great tom has been you know it's not an
easy road just because you got Tom Brady
even though they've got some good pieces
I'm and I just got the schedule up in
front of me I mean at home you got Green
Bay Kansas City Minnesota the Saints
obviously the Falcons Carolina the Rams
and the Chargers I don't know when
either quarterbacks in but that's their
home schedule I mean that's eight games
against teams that were either in the
playoffs or vying for the playoffs for
the most part last year so yeah I mean
he's obviously I say an upgrade an
upgrade from the standpoint that I
thought Jameis did a lot of really good
things last year but he just got in his
way too much and that's the one thing
you know it's on Brady you're not gonna
turn the ball over so if you can even
get you know
we force the production at Jamie's head
and you cut those interceptions in about
a fourth you know what does that mean
for this team you're you're probably
right there are 10 11 12 win team if
everything comes together and you have
to believe they're gonna be a little bit
better because they were young
especially defensively lashes they're
gonna be even a little better on that
side of the ball than they were well I'm
not you know a walk-in Pro Football
Focus here and I don't know
you know how the percentages change blah
blah blah but you'd have to think with
the 30 interceptions we know a handful
of them were pick sixes but the the
field flipping that would happen that
would put the defense on their heels in
that defense that Todd Bowles had last
year was number one against the rush I
mean they could just shut people down on
the run and make it more of a
one-dimensional game and if Brady can
again as you say cut him by three
quarters down to just one quarter of the
number of interceptions to them alone
would cascade and ripple effect on this
team that was out seven and seven with
all of those turnovers from just the
quarterback you know I think back to the
game that you guys called down in Tampa
right you know lay the year against the
Texans who was playoff team and you know
the Texans squeaked that one out but if
it wasn't for a couple early
interceptions but pick six right off the
bat by Jameis and that's what we saw you
you mentioned I think the last row that
he made in a Tampa uniform I believe it
was against Atlanta where he threw that
pick section in overtime you know and
again another game that's right there
you know with the ability to be had so
I'm with you
but you know the thing that we know in
this business is that you can't just
take last year and then fit it into this
year and add pieces there's so much it
has to do with chemistry and timing and
figuring out how that works and as we
said the schedule and other teams you
know are they gonna be better land I
mean you look at Atlanta you were
talking about Todd Gurley you look at
Atlanta's starting offense right they
got like 10 guys that were you know
first-round draft picks now they haven't
played that well lately but I just look
at that team and I go and this team
could explode at any point in time as
well Carolina what does Teddy
Bridgewater bring to the table I think
we know the Saints are going to be
really good so
again I think he improves them but how
much and how is the schedule look and
how do these other team shake out but
it's it gives us something to talk about
for sure and it makes the NFC I think
really wide open and really tough
because there are so many teens and so
many quarterbacks over there it's going
to be really fun what do you make of the
news again Rick's drought and tampo has
been covering the team reporting and
then in the Peter Kings football morning
in America piece that came out just
today that Bruce Arians and Jason light
hadn't even spoken to Brady till
Wednesday what did you make so we must
begin you know lean in Tampa's direction
before I even spoke to Aryans do you
know I think it's a little bit
fascinating but I wonder if you also
when you're going through this process
you feel like Tom Brady had an idea on
why he wanted to go different places and
why he would consider different places
and you know I sit back and I wonder
yeah I'm sure a part of it was football
related but I'm not sure that was the
biggest part I think he wanted to change
a senior I think he wanted something
that was you know close to his family
you know everybody's reporting that you
know his son is in that New York area
you want to stay on the East Coast so
maybe this was one of those situations
where he really had a sense very early
on when the market shrunk to to just a
couple teams well I mean Tampa's my best
shot so I know of Coach aryans I know
Coach Ariens do I need to really talk to
him and have him sell me on the
situation or is it more big picture and
going what's the best fit for me
regardless of the other stuff let me
just find the best fit it's Tampa and
let's go well I would even you know
supposing because that's what we do when
we're bored and sitting in
shelter-in-place that maybe Brady even
reached out to Peyton you know he and
Ian Peyton of seemingly maintained much
closer touch than perhaps anybody would
let on because of the so called rivalry
for all those years
but you know everybody down in Tampa
Peyton's very familiar with
and I'm sure Brady is very familiar with
Payton's mode of offense and whether he
could fit in it right I mean and then
again you point out about what happened
last year in the game that I called on
that week 16 Saturday in advance of your
bills Patriots game that you called and
and that game where Winston threw a pick
six that got called back only to allow
the Texans to score and then a pick six
for real the next time that game they
were in that at the very end there was
no Godwin there was no Evans in that
game they were literally down to people
whose name tags would not needed to be
used for Jameson they were in the huddle
that's for real so I'm just wondering if
that might have played a role in it you
know well I mean again I think you can
look at the pieces and be excited from
that standpoint I don't think that's a
part of it I think you can look at Bruce
Arians
resume you know no matter where it's
been where there's been a coordinator
with the Steelers where the head coach
in Arizona you know what he did with
Jameis last year and again 30 and 30 but
you're looking at Jameis Winston and
threw for 5,000 yards and 30 touchdowns
you know I mean I think all the pieces
are right out there in front of you do I
really necessarily need to have a
conversation to go oh well yeah this
guy's a good coach or this guy can help
me or they've got the pieces that I
really wonder if this was more Tom Brady
hunkering down with this family here's
the market here's the teams I believe I
can win anywhere I think I can be
successful anywhere what's the best fit
for us and you know maybe that's part of
why he didn't really have to do the
extensive traveling and you know and
talked to a bunch of people because it
was bigger than that you know it was
bigger than you know than just what team
gives me the best chance to win where's
the right fit for me and my family
because you have to believe that's why
this move was made as much as anything
was it was just time time to move the
family go somewhere else try something
new and it just seems like Tampa was the
best fit so well in the few minutes we
have left here let's hit some other
quarterback situations here man I can't
believe that cam might have to look at
accepting a backup role somewhere to
prove
it's foots fine or to prove something
you know and obviously you know what
it's like to be a super bowl-winning as
opposed to he went to one Super Bowl
quarterback just purely identified with
one organization and then have to find a
new way I wonder what you think is going
on in Cam's mind right now yeah well I
mean it's fascinating as you said I was
in a very similar situation one two MVPs
what the two Super Bowls and then the
perception was out there when the Rams
released me that I was damaged goods
right that I couldn't play I couldn't be
the same quarterback I was before and
that's a tough place to be because as
you know in this business perception is
reality you know what is out there and
what people think you know the shoulder
that the foot you can't be the same guy
people believe that and so it becomes
they show me what have you done for me
lately lately type League and that's why
I did it take that stint with the Giants
was just to try to prove to people
because it was really the only shot I
could find of being a starting
quarterback knowing that they were
drafting Eli being a starting
quarterback in hopes to prove in that
one season hey I can still play this
game and parlay that into another
starting job and so you know you look at
cam and I have to believe everybody's
looking at it that way and and I think
it's twofold with Cam as well too
because not only injuries and is he
going to be healthy but he was such a
different type of quarterback you know
the running quarterback our quarterback
you know the ability to run in those
short yardage situations not necessarily
a true drop at quarterback and so I
think the other facet of this this
team's looking and going okay if we do
get Cam and even if he's healthy can he
be that Cam Newton again who are now is
he more relegated to being a drop back
pass or and if so what time to drop that
pass what kind of player will he be if
he's more fit into that role and so I
think there's just a whole bunch of
questions with that um you know but but
that being said you know our league is
in a good place
quarterback wise but this is Cam Newton
too and he is a special beast and yeah
he might have to go to a place where it
looks like they've got a guy as a
starter or he's going to have to compete
for it
that's what we do as competitors right
that's what we do is yeah it's nice to
be have the job given to you but there's
something about going in and saying hey
just give me a chance and I will prove
to you who I am and what I can be and it
sure looks like that's probably gonna be
Kim's situation outside of maybe you
know there's New England take a shot to
go that route even though they've got a
young guy and kind of the same thing
Jerris not ready yet let's bring in a
Cam Newton and see what we get for a
year if we can get two or three years
out this guy special player he was then
we have that back-up plan
I don't know I'm fascinated you know cuz
Jameis - Jameis is open now guy just
threw for 5,000 yards and 13 touchdowns
and I mean he did a lot of good things
last year you know looking you know the
Chargers I mean great situation with a
lot of weapons is Tyrod the right guy to
be able to utilize all those weapons
although he probably won't make the
mistakes but I'm just I'm fascinated by
a couple of these situations and how
it's gonna play out Andy Dalton is
another guy that I'm a huge fan of may
not have the upside of some of these
quarterbacks but he does a lot of things
really really well and in the right fit
with a good team around him he's
definitely a playoff quarterback he's
shown us that too so what route do they
go with Andy Dalton it and there's only
handful of teams a few teams out there
that really need a quarterback even from
a competitive standpoint that again I'm
fascinated we had a lot of moves and
free agency but I'm really fascinated
what happens with these quarterbacks
well I'm wondering with this with the
signing of Hoyer in New England I'm
wondering if Belichick is sitting back
and letting the market come to him but
that I mean what the draft happened
let's see what happens in the draft
because I'm assuming the Chargers move
here is let's keep Tehran Taylor here
he's a veteran who's been in the
playoffs before he did that with the
bills although they were points
challenged in that game against
Jacksonville State at least but maybe
just sitting back and letting the market
come to him by saying let's see who
takes the quarterback what the Chargers
will take their quarterback the Dolphins
will take their quarterback I think
they're definitely going to take two
which means Josh Rosen
might pop free the Bengals will
obviously take their quarterback won't
won't be able to one would think
keep Baro and Dalton although Dalton
would be a great guy to have on your
team to have Baro
mentor by him although I don't know how
much he wants to play the role of mr.
chips I'm just wondering what Belichick
is doing right there because I think I
know what the charge is like hey let's
let's go you know shoot our shot with
Brady that's the only way that would
take us out of our plan of let's stick
with Taylor go draft somebody but I'm
wondering if that's what Bella checks
plan is by hiring Hoyer right now to get
in that humid student I would not be
surprised in the least bit if they
believed Stidham is the next guy you
know I think that's really the question
and you know you hear the good signs and
what they saw they truly believe he's
the next guy then I wouldn't be
surprised at all because you have to
believe you can get one of these veteran
guys and if you can get one or two years
out of them to play and be that stopgap
believing you've got your future and if
it happens soon or it happens sooner
that would be the perfect mix and as you
said you know these other teams that
need one you know Tyrod Taylor Taylor
and the Chargers that's probably not
your long-term fix right right so you
what do they do I can't imagine them go
and sign cam for a long-term deal Jameis
I think again I think is an interesting
because he's a young guy still and he's
done some really good things where does
he end up I think that's a key piece in
this whole thing but yeah I wouldn't be
surprised
Chargers sitting in the right spot going
hey man maybe we can get up there and
and you know get to uh and and have our
guy for the future and how that plays
out that and because the fact that like
you said there's there's three veterans
that you know talk about those guys
Jameis Cam and Andy Dalton you know if
you're Bill Belichick you're going
keeping with those guys I mean I had one
of the best defenses in the league last
year all right you give me one of those
guys we will be successful and we still
have our plan moving forward so yeah I
would not be surprised by that in the
least bit if he just kind of waited this
out and see if even even if these
quarterbacks will sign before the draft
I mean you think those quarterbacks will
go off the board
before the draft or it will be let's
wait and see who we get if we're those
other teams and then then we'll go get
the veteran wife maybe they won't
because you know as you know in the
world we're living in right now there's
not gonna be any offseason workouts
there's not gonna be any places opening
for business in April and handing off
the playbook to people then because of
kovat 19 and I've always I've said now
anybody that sounds like Philip in my
mind Philip Rivers should have the
PlayBook in his hand right now because
the only reason why you're holding a
playbook off from players in March is
usually the reason for this is to is to
take the pressure off of the players and
from from being made to feel like
they're less than a good teammate
because they're not studying all the
time or that they're being pressured by
management to come in there this needs
to be just this regular cooling-off
period but now we're all being cooled
off I think they should give them the
playbook right then and there but that's
I don't want to go down that wormhole
but so I don't think these guys will
sign right now maybe they should back
and wait and in terms of Jameis and then
I just want to move on to one more
quarterback situation with you Peter
King came on the show a couple weeks he
going through the Steelers out there
that that maybe Jameis signs with the
Steelers he's their quarterback of the
future if Ben isn't ready this year and
he looks like he's part of the duck
dynasty cast as we saw over the last
couple of days and that if he's not
ready to go maybe Jameis is the guy
since we saw him play musical chairs
that Mason Rudolph and duck Hodges
wasn't working out that maybe that might
not be a bad spot for him to land in
Pittsburgh not at all not at all I mean
cuz you know I mean these teams have to
start thinking of that next plan I mean
Ben I think has two more years on his
contract and with the injury I mean you
just probably not gonna play beyond that
but who knows so yeah I mean I again I
think Jameis is fascinating because
Jameis has done so many good things in
this league and everybody just looks at
him and goes well if we can just
eliminate the interceptions now you know
we've seen plenty of guys that we said
that throughout their entire career and
they never get to that point but that's
why he's so intriguing because he does
so many
things I mean I watched you know I watch
all the film every week and he makes
more throws and more big-time decisions
than most quarterbacks in this league
and it excites me every time I watch him
or I talk to him about it you know but
it just again you gotta at some point be
able to delineate between what's a good
you know good attempt and what's a bad
attempt and he just hasn't figured that
out yet
and you know team like the Steelers or
somebody else I think has to be
intrigued by that especially if they
don't have to pay him big dollars right
and go man maybe we can be that guy you
know maybe we can be that team maybe he
can mature maybe he can work through it
but if we're not tied in for the long
term I think it's very intriguing for
you know one of these teams that knows
their guy is probably moving closer to
retirement you know I mean the Saints
and I know Jason mill might be their guy
for the future but you know Drew's got a
couple more years and then you know
cookie learned from Jameis could he you
know become that next guy again to me
one of the most fascinating you know
parts of this kind of free agency with
with the quarterback position last one
for you put you in another position that
you've been in in your in your life
Super Bowl MVP on going to yet another
team and needing to either mentor or
push or displace a highly drafted
quarterback yours was Matt Leinart
now I'm talking about Nick Foles showing
up at Chicago
I mean Chicago I mean it's amazing one
year after he was a huge free agent
signing in Jacksonville hitting the
jackpot for him
well-deserved now he's traded for a
fourth round compensatory pick on the
next new league year to Chicago what in
the world do you think Nick Foles role
is in Chicago right now fascinating
because they've got a great situation I
think for Nick Foles you know Nick Foles
to me I'm not sure he's the guy that you
know made the 30 million dollars I'm not
sure he's the guy that you go here go
throw the ball 35 40 times worse and win
games force with your right arm that's
never really been him he's been a good
leader he's been able
managed games extremely well for
whatever reason he's a leader he's able
to get the best out of the team
around him so it fascinates me with the
Chicago team it's got a great defense is
going to be in most games and they need
a guy to come in and lead make the plays
they're supposed to make not have to do
anything special yet they've got this
young quarterback that they you know
went up and God and put a lot into
that's really struggled I think this is
really gonna be one of those situations
where I think you find out a lot about
players when you bring a guy in to look
over their shoulder that everybody knows
can play everybody know is a leader to
see how you respond to that you know
what is mystery Biscay going to do I
believe he goes in as the starter but I
think Nick is gonna push him in every
way shape or form and just more than
anything be a presence right there to
say you mess up I got this you know I
got this and I can run with this and so
I think we're really gonna see whom it's
true Biscay is is one of those things
that can either catapult guys forward
and allowed them to become a competitor
and learn how to play at this level or
guys shrink and they worry about every
mistake and they worry about every throw
and it starts to eat them up and I
really think that's what Chicago said is
that we're gonna bring in a guy that we
know we can win with and we know that
can lead our organization we still want
Mitch to be that guy but we are gonna
put the pressure on him to see which way
he goes well I mean that's the one thing
in all those tests they don't we'll end
up with this is what does it mean push
because if he was supposed to if he was
the second overall selection that they
wanted him to be he wouldn't need to be
pushed they wouldn't have to bring in
somebody to push him right I mean isn't
this some sort of admission that it's
not working out what does that mean like
no right I mean no I don't think there's
any question it's it's you know an
indication that it's not working the way
they want it to work but as I said
there's times when you're in a situation
where you kind of know you're the guy
and regardless of what happens you look
behind you and you go look they're not
given the reins to bad guy you know that
that's not the guy that's going to lead
them into the future not that the
they're behind me isn't good but that's
not what's going to happen and so you
can get that you know sense of security
where it's kind of like I got this no
matter if I screw up or whatever pushing
to me is going okay we just brought
somebody in to let you know that is not
the case anymore we just brought in a
Super Bowl MVP a Super Bowl champion
that came in as a backup and led his
team to the Super Bowl this is it you
know this is this is your chance to
prove it and I don't believe he's got a
very long leash now whereas I believe
the past couple years because of how it
played out and more importantly who the
guy was behind him that he knew and
everybody knew we just got to go down
this path and we got to see what we're
gonna take what we get but we have
nowhere else to go now Chicago saying
we've got somewhere else to go and we
want it to be him and they don't want to
be wrong but at the same time they've
got a back-up plan and that to me is
pushing that again every throw that
Mitch makes in training camp is going to
be weighed against everything that Nick
Foles does and Mitch knows that and
that's the you know to me it's a
fascinating part when you get in there
is what do you do in those situations
when you screw up can you let that go
and not worry about what's behind you
and nuts and make the next throw or does
one bad throw turn to a next turn to a
next and it starts to to show who you're
probably gonna be under those pressure
situations alright thanks for doing this
Curt you're our first zoom guest in the
history of the [ __ ] Dyson show and
you're gonna be the first of I assume
many they're gonna be zooming in from
their home office so I'm gonna make this
a little bit of an end part of those
segments behind you walk me through that
is that that looks like an espy next to
a painting Man of the Year award
right I mean like is that what it is up
there
honest I don't know what I don't know
what you see up there so you go to your
left look in here you know all the way
to the left up there that looks like is
that your Walter Payton Man of the Year
award right right there so with that is
there no that's an athlete's in action
that is an SP all right well it's
obviously the MVP trophy yeah Super Bowl
MVP this is the MVP quarterback Rob I
don't I don't know sorry I had to go up
and read him I wasn't really sure what
was up
Oh they've been up there for a while
thanks for mentioning that make me
believe it again nice muj as long as you
don't come and try to take him out of my
office make me feel irrelevant yeah okay
and that helmet that's it's uh I see
there's one up there right
what does that helmet that's right
there's over the silver one I'd like
there's a Cardinal emblem on it so it's
just cool yeah the other one over there
is just a Super Bowl helmet it's signed
by a couple people I'm not sure who
signed it so yeah I guess it's my little
shrine here in my pocket it's got books
I got books you got books I mean I use
another pair of glasses yeah well come
on we got to pump that up a little bit
come on I got these the Zoom TV show yes
that you're doing it's gonna is gonna
win an award and then we're gonna get
you an Emmy for hosting our show here
this year I can all the coverage that
you did you know throughout the
offseason it's time we got it we got to
load that thing up with some words if
not you can have a couple of mine we'll
make it look really really good all
right best of Brenda and your family man
stay safe and healthy things you're
doing this bird same to you best the
kids and the fam tell soon as we said a
lot hello you got a buddy take it easy
there's nobody right here on this
addition to Rich Eisen show